hello and welcome back to the edinburgh
television festival i'm joined now by
the bbc's chief content officer
charlotte moore charlemont good
afternoon to you thank you so much for
being with us look emily maitlis made
some very stinging concerns about the
bbc last night um was she right is there
tory cronies at the heart of the bbc
absolutely not i mean there was no
influence whatsoever uh would have come
down for any we do policy editorial
policy was followed due process was
followed there was a breach and
editorial guidelines we make it very
clear to our journalists and to our
staff what we expect from impartiality
and that means leaving your personal
opinions at the door and i think that's
what audiences want i think viewers
really
you know trust that the bbc will be
impartial we know that's what defines us
it's the cornerstone of the bbc and we
have we've made it a priority and we'll
continue to do so i mean that's
specifically on the way she behaved in
those tweets and you're right there was
a there was punishment for that but she
was talking about a man called robbie
gibb who's now on the bbc board formerly
from gb news former conservative party
member um that's the question isn't it
about having someone like that on the
bbc board and the dangers that may well
categorically not true that there was
any influence over any appointments
categorically not true so uh no i just i
don't recognize that it doesn't happen i
don't believe him where did she get it
from then it's not just if it's just not
true why would she why would you think
that was an issue because because there
was no influence and due process have
been followed in all of those issues and
i can absolutely say to you there was no
no influence from the board or from
government of course i'll take you to
work but you see the issue that there is
with that with someone like robbie give
being on the board of the beauty and i
think anybody who joins the board
anybody who sit to any leadership
position at the bbc absolutely has to
leave their views at the door when they
come in look in barcelona she's a big
conversation both at the board exco
level across the whole of the bbc tim
davey our director general has made it a
priority and we all really believe
particularly in these feral times we
believe you know it's really challenging
to deliver impartial news particularly
when you challenge government and
politicians and it's incredibly
important that we hold on to our
impartiality so you know that's
absolutely why it's very important as i
say we make it very clear that we leave
any personal opinions at the door and
you're confident that robbie gibb who
worked for gb news is leaving all his
personal opinions on the team he has to
that's what we also
talked about this uh both sidedness as
well and she talked about this example
of where they were trying to find an
economist who was clicking brexit it
took them two minutes to find six and
you know took five hours to find the
chief content officer i'm not across all
the details of news but i think both
side of them is absolutely fascinating
isn't it and i think due impartiality is
something we really have to focus on i
don't think it's about extreme views on
either side and that gives you balance
it doesn't give you balance i think you
absolutely have to think about
impartiality and this will do
impartiality on any subject we're a
really interesting time in history right
now and i think that's where the
criticism comes in about having
robbie being on the board with the the
current governments that's had its
prevails i think we'll put it politely
having someone like that on the board
who perhaps will have some influence is
a concerning time look the bbc is is
independent it has to act independently
it has to be impartial that is what we
are all signed up to and we cannot take
influence from government or influence
from politicians and that's that's
that's what we all sign up to at the bbc
and we really agree with you so
independence of the bbc is critical to
its success absolutely absolutely and so
essentially you support the argument
that she's making and you think there is
no there's no danger support we have to
make sure that we
we bring independent news that we are
not influenced by government that we are
able to challenge and hold governments
and politicians to account on all sides
of the political spectrum you know let's
face it impartiality isn't just about
politics it's about diversity of views
and opinion but it's about do
impartiality it's not about
extreme views that equal balance so you
know that's my take she just disgruntled
she's just a disgruntled former employee
no i think look this is we welcome the
debate i mean i think you know it's a
really important subject and i thought
the tiger was absolutely it feels very
timely in this world of populism as she
says and both side of them and you know
i i thought those were all really
interesting subjects for all of us to
vape and i think when we talk about
impartiality i actually really welcome
the fact we're having these quite
nuanced conversations about what we mean
by that because i think it's really
important for viewers to understand and
to value the bbc for the fact we do
promise impartial independent trusted
news and i think that's incredibly
valuable in a world where a lot of news
is commercially you know it's
commercially driven it's profit driven
it's a gender driven um and that's not
what the bbc is it comes from but that's
what the bbc promises so i think for
audiences that's absolutely critical to
what we're here to do and i think it
defines us it's why public service
broadcasting has been such a big part of
this festival i went to a session
yesterday morning with a group of you
know big independent
suppliers who were all talking about the
need for public service broadcasting to
be supported and i think that's what the
bbc you know that's what defines it and
therefore i think look i think
impartiality is absolutely you know
welcome that topic to be it's one of our
priorities i think it should be a
priority across the whole of the
industry
oh yeah that's absolutely right
charlotte i could talk to you about this
we'll have to know about it yeah leave
you there thank you so much thank you
very much